le couloir est en général et 1 il ya le
minimum de bruit on parle pas fort dans
les chambres des enfants le plus petit
pèse à peine 600 g c'est ici que les
bébés prématurés sont prises en charge
un nouveau service de néonatologie du
centre hospitalier de versailles
équipé de 18 lits dont six en soins
intensifs
on est passé d'un unités néonatologie
qui étaient affiliés au service de
pédiatrie pendant très longtemps et que
en fait on a pu créer le service est
paré pour pouvoir avoir en même temps
des lits de soins intensifs qu'il n'y
avait pas dans le secteur est de pouvoir
fournir sa à la population locale un
besoin pour le sud yvelines
auparavant les parents étaient souvent
séparés de leurs enfants transférés à
paris ou dans le nord du département
inauguré en septembre ce nouveau service
s'inscrit dans un plan global de
modernisation de l'hôpital
la maternité aussi a fait peau neuve et
s'est agrandi le bâtiment mignot existe
depuis 81
la maternité est arrivé ici uniquement
96 mais l'été a été notoirement sous
dimensionné à l'époque
moi je suis chef de service ici depuis
2002 et donc en 2002 j'ai écrit un
projet pour dimensionner cette maternité
en fonction des besoins de la population
enfin on ouvre on ouvre un bâtiment qui
est bien conçu qui est lumineux qui va
pouvoir accueillir 3500 naissance
autre nouveauté la maternité a également
développé les médecines alternatives
comme l'acupuncture ou l'hypnose cinq
ans de travaux 34 millions d'euros
d'investissement le prix à payer pour
permettre aux yvelinoise d'accoucher
près de chez elle en sécurité